along this Atlantic Coastline entire
communities are being Swept Away here in
Lagos more than 180 kilm of the coast
has been taken over by the ocean most of
it in the last
decade official here say the problem is
accelerating at a frightening Pace we
have um I I would say about about 155 km
of groins in plates uh which is one of
the things we're putting in place to to
to deal with with the current the the
imbalance of the wind wave and current
um in that case we've only been able to
do to cover a distance of about uh in
total I would say about 15.5 km and we
have a total of 180 km stretch climate
change is blamed for some of it but
man-made problems like sand Ming and
illegal Reclamation of land from the
ocean are also making Coastal erosion
worse
over the past two decades Community
leaders in fun say they lost 90% of
their land look the bad there's no more
land for us to move into because the
remaining property there belongs to Chev
Nigeria
limited Community leaders say the beach
used to be 2 km away from here and that
was just 10 years ago since then they've
moved four times and resettled in land
and now I new beach front is being
formed where houses used to be just a
few years ago Lagos is home to more than
20 million people living on just 3,300
square
kilm as his population increases there
is a rush for land and sand for
construction the Atlantic Ocean and its
beaches here are the
targets after they brought a boat to
mine sand the erosion and encroachment
got worse that's how we got into bigger
trouble a bigger worry for Nigerian
Coastal communities is the overlapping
jurisdictions of federal and state
governments on access to Natural
Resources each wants exclusive rights
environmentalists want an immediate ban
on the exploitation of coastal areas
unless that is done they say Nigeria's
most popular state may soon run out of
space to accommodate its growing
population Ahmed rris aljer Alpha Okun
Legos
Nigeria make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jaaz